why so tired connor i i was up all night
and then i didn't sleep very well and i
was considering canceling my japanese
lesson
because i can cancel it online yeah but
if i do it like uh
after 6 p.m the day before i don't get
my money back oh really
so it's like wait do you pay every
lesson it's not like a like a monthly
thing
you pay for like tokens and then
what like the tokens you can like this
is like gotcha currency
yes that's what i was thinking right
not everything's [ __ ] gotcha with you
guys
like so how do you earn tokens can you
earn tokens by just
going to win currency called money i
don't know if you've heard of it can you
claim them like in-game as well
you guys have been playing gotcha too
much like do you have like dailies for
like
every every lesson you go to there's
like dailies
you get like five tokens a day i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna ignore it like
finally i can do my temple
no you're gonna you can explain now
connor okay finally are the jokes done
yeah you just you pay and then you get
like uh
x amount of lessons with it but like
private lessons cost more
right like class lessons cost x i'm sure
people can figure out which school i'm
going to now
i mean someone already [ __ ] did
someone like approached me really yeah
they like i was talking with my teacher
it was like a common area
and because you had like a 10 minute
break and we were talking and then some
guy was like hey
are you like the guy on youtube and i'm
like
which guy the guy like
i guess i am you know the white british
guy i've already told the story on the
podcast though
but yeah i mean so yeah that's it and
i'm tired as [ __ ] because i went to it
and i was like i probably should have
cancelled and you slept in but yeah yeah
yeah you knew fully well we were gonna
do a podcast episode today i did i did
but
i've been doing it every week with a
lesson before i'm like i'm like
impressed that we've been able to manage
like this weekly schedule without taking
a single week off since we started i
think right i think so i mean we've
maybe had one
off but other than that we've been
pretty consistent we've had one off
simply because one of the cameras broke
for this one week that's right one of
the cameras
yeah yeah but but to compensate we did
two episodes once yeah
yeah cause i'm sure it's obvious the
views at home but this setup has all
been set up by like i guess
us mainly me but we just chill
so when like the camera died and i
didn't know what i was doing i was like
oh
[ __ ] okay um i guess we're not filming
today yeah
it turned out one of the cameras was
broke and we had to get it fixed yeah
for no reason either we never figured
that out yeah